madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour
nous avons commencé dans un instant
monsieur cinéma dans sa nouvelle formule
mais bien sûr nous prenons l'actualité
cinématographique en route car vous le
savez la saison commence vers la fin du
mois d'août à paris maintenant et dans
toutes les grandes villes aussi et il ya
donc des films dont nous n'avons pas
parlé
alors nous jetons un coup d'oeil sur les
affiches des films dont nous aurions pu
vous parler si monsieur cinéma avait
repris plus tôt nous vous aurions parlé
par exemple du dernier film de visconti
c'est-à-dire l'innocent ce film qui est
son dernier film puisqu'il est mort
depuis
nous vous avions parlé d'un type comme
moi ne devrait jamais mourir qui est un
premier film de michel vianey l'affiché
signée folon vous connaissez bien jean
michel folon mais il joue aussi le rôle
principal dans ce film
et puis ingmar bergman face à face avec
liv ullmann il y a aussi dans les
nouveaux films et déjà dans l'actualité
depuis quelques semaines duel avec
juliet berto et bulle ogier duel de
jacques rivette
quand tu disais valérie qui est un film
tout à fait particulier puisque c'est
une production du centre de culture
populaire de saint nazaire
il y a les voyages de gulliver le film
le dessin animé de fléchères que l'on
peut revoir buffalo bills et les indiens
film dartmann avec paul newman dans le
rôle de buffalo bill
le dernier stanley kubrick barry lyndon
de stanley kubrick qui a fait vous le
savez 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace ou
orange mécanique
joël séria qui nous donne l année
dernière les galettes de pont-aven
revient avec jeanne goupil et andré
dussolier dans mary poupée et puis enfin
un vieux camarade un camarade de notre
enfance
king kong oui king kong on peut le
retrouver sur les écrans
le voici
monsieur sabria bonjour monsieur je suis
très heureux de vous retrouver après de
longues vacances et nous vous retrouvons
dans un décor différent et nous allons
vous retrouvez avec un jeu différent
vous avez retrouvé ce pendant le
générique composé par notre ami jean
christophe averty sur une musique de
gérard calvi mais monsieur sabria vous
avez participé à monsieur cinéma et vous
étiez le vainqueur d'ailleurs avant les
vacances et vous vous retrouvez dans un
nouveau jeu vous êtes tout seul c'est
que en fait notre formule a changé et
cette année nous allons faire jouer un
concurrent contre lui même monsieur
sabria va donc être là opposée à
lui-même c'est-à-dire tentant de faire
le contrat que nous lui proposons
comment ça va se passer et bien je vous
l'expliqué rapidement car les
explications de jeu sont toujours
embarrassante et embarrassé dans un jeu
de télévision faisons vite mais je
sabria est là pour un maximum de cinq
semaines
si je m'adresse à vous chers
téléspectateurs c'est parce que le
salariat lui est déjà au courant du
règlement et qu'il l'a accepté de venir
jouer avec nous cinq semaines à la fin
de la cinquième semaine vous pouvez
gagner la somme de 20000 francs
mais vous pourrez aussi abandonné à la
fin de la quatrième semaine vous aurez
gagné dix mille faux mais pendant les
trois semaines précédentes il faudra
absolument essayer de tenir le contrat
que nous vous propose chaque semaine
vous aurez 5 épreuves et ses cinq
épreuves seront constituées par quinze
questions nous vous demandons la
première semaine de faire dix points sur
15 la deuxième semaine de faire 11
points sur 15
troisième semaine 12 points sur 15 la
quatrième semaine treize points sur
quinze et la dernière semaine nous vous
demandons de faire 15 sur 15
mais attention les points que vous aurez
pu accumuler dans les semaines
précédentes disons le bonus qui sont
constitués d'ailleurs par des petits
charlot que nous avons pensé que charlot
est l emblème le plus frappant du cinéma
depuis sa naissance
eh bien les petits charlot vous aurez
accumulé dans les semaines précédentes
vous pourront vous permettre de vous
rattraper si à la dernière et
terrifiante semaine vous ne parvenez pas
au 15
les cinq semaines seront constitués de
la façon suivante la première semaine
nous interrogerons monsieur sabria où
les autres candidats qui viendront après
lui nous interrogerons sur le cinéma
français d origine jusqu'à 1944 la
deuxième semaine le cinéma français de
1944 à nos jours la troisième semaine ce
sera le cinéma étranger
la quatrième semaine celle où il faut
faire 13 points sur 15
ça sera un genre particulier du cinéma
que le candidat aura choisi lui même et
la cinquième semaine ce sera des
questions sur une personnalité du cinéma
choisi elle aussi par le candidat lui
même c'est à dire que la quatrième
semaine monsieur sabria vous pouvez
prendre le western le cinéma policier le
suspense la comédie musicale la
cinquième semaine vous pouvez prendre
jean renoir fritz lang rené clair john
wayne jacques prévert enfin une
personnalité du cinéma dont vous avez
envie de parler
qu'est-ce que vous choisissez pour la
quatrième semaine pour le genre eh ben
je prendrai le genre historique
les reconstitutions historiques c'est à
dire les films à costumes les films à
costumes très bien et la cinquième
semaine une personnalité du cinéma
j'aimerais bien entendre et danielle
darrieux danielle darrieux charmante
idée voilà une comédienne que nous
aimons beaucoup
et bien voilà c'est enregistré c'est
ainsi que nous opérons je vous souhaite
en tout cas que tout se passe bien je
vous souhaite de réussir être première
semaine est d'être là encore avec nous
si vous perdez cette semaine je vous
donnerai comme d'habitude des places
offertes par le centre du cinéma et une
innovation le jeu monsieur cinéma
car voyez vous dans notre émission un
jeu comme tant d'autres le jeu monsieur
cinéma qui est inspiré donne notre
émission alors voilà nous commençons
avec monsieur sabria la première semaine
de notre nouveau jeu
monsieur cinéma
et bien voici notre première semaine
mais il est bien évident que monsieur
cinéma est une émission consacrée à
l'actualité cinématographique nous
allons vous proposer monsieur sabria de
jeter un coup d'oeil avec les
spectateurs sur les nouveaux films qui
vont arriver sur les écrans cette
semaine
et voici tout d'abord un éléphant ça
trompe énormément
c'est le nouveau